nicolas sarkozy qui dans son discours
d'une heure trente a dressé un bilan de
sa campagne affiché sa volonté de
tourner la page avec la france de mai 68
et tendent une nouvelle fois la main aux
électeurs du centre sur place reportage
michaël darmon jean marc notebook bercy
où le concours d'applaudimètre pour les
politiques à une semaine deuxième tour
ils bataillent contré ce jour pour les
postes en cas de victoire de nicolas
sarkozy sur l'écran géant
chacun cherche à forme de choc qu'il
faut c'est dans les coeurs dans les
rangs des élus et des ministres rien
n'est anodin françois fillon possible
premier ministre en cas de victoire de
nicolas sarkozy est très entourée c'est
la loi du genre
nicolas sarkozy ça ne vous a pas échappé
a dit qu' il y aurait 15 personnes dans
le gouvernement donc je participe ont
savouré ce moment parce qu'il y aura
certainement beaucoup
déception tandis traille et le show
politique continue nicolas sarkozy parle
à l'extérieur même si je suis avec
dominique de villepin a quant à lui fait
son entrée juste pour écouter le
candidat ump à l'elysée
moi je veux aller à la rencontre du
peuple de ce peuple au nom duquel tout
le monde prétend parler et auquel
personne ne parle plus et puisque
monsieur bayrou doit en finir avec l'udf
jeudi aux cellules de l'udf qui me
soutiennent qu'ils sont les bienvenus en
femmes et hommes libres dans la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle à bercy nicolas
sarkozy a voulu à la fois impressionné
et séduire les électeurs indécis avant
le prochain temps fort son débat face à
ségolène royal